obviously you know you've been working
on this book for a while
and it it is current in the sense that
it it you know tackles uh covid
in some regard but obviously it predates
the capital
insurrection and you know aspects of q
anon and some of the other
you know kind of things that we're
seeing unfold right now when you were
watching
the capital insurrection how are you
thinking about
the ideas presented in the book and how
these these things kind of you know
coalesce it it was a shock was was the
first thing i
never thought that an insurrection would
happen in america
it's something you read about happening
in other countries and
thank your lucky stars that we don't
live in one of those countries
and you know the i as an organizational
psychologist i've spent most of my
careers
trying to study things that are timeless
and i've really deliberately resisted
the timely
because i'm interested in ideas not news
i'm interested in
you know in rigorous evidence not
current events
and yet this idea of thinking again
uh it i finished the book right around a
time when we're dealing with the
greatest polarization i've ever seen and
you know then an attack
on our very democracy and my first
thought was
you know what everyone's now calling the
big lie that you know the election was
stolen from donald trump
if we could have gotten many people to
rethink their belief
in that lie it's possible the the
insurrection wouldn't have happened at
all
and my next thought was okay most of
these people
don't seem to think that they're
undermining democracy
they think they're saving democracy and
that requires a whole re-examination of
you know not just a belief but a belief
system a world view
and i don't i don't know that that i
know how to tackle that
i think i have you know i have some
ideas and insights about how to begin to
chip away at some of those wrong beliefs
but
i think it's an extreme i guess my
reaction was
there's a sequel to this book that needs
to be written about conspiracy theories
about false news that is very different
from
i was trying to deal with what i thought
was you know everyday resistance to
admitting that you're wrong
and to knowing what you don't know and i
think what your question makes me wonder
is
is is the everyday version of that now
extreme enough
that we need that book for more people
than i realized yeah i i i would like to
read that book i think there is
something
qualitatively different now
about the way that we uh
you know are magnetized by certain ideas
and the conspiracy theory is its own
kind of genus in all of this i mean you
did talk about it in the book
you have the example of the flat earther
and you have that graphic that circular
graphic
but when you think about conspiracy
theories
in general you're dealing with
a set of people who are under the belief
that they're the ones who are thinking
more open-minded
about this idea they're the ones who
have taken the red pill
they're they're seeing things that are
seeing things more clearly
they're standing outside of the
conventional wisdom
and that makes it very different than
some other kind of well-held belief that
that
you know informs identity yeah it does
and it is
i think i i think this is it's a huge
uphill battle i've been reading a lot
lately about the psychology of
conspiracy theories why people adopt
them and especially
why or when they might be willing to
reconsider them
and i think it's hard to it's hard to
have this conversation without talking
about cognitive dissonance
right dating back to the classic leon
festenger work
which basically said if you've already
committed to a belief
then any threats to that belief if they
if they force you to treat the world as
a less
pleasant place for you uh to you know to
challenge your ego
to put aside you know pre-existing
commitments you've made to
walk back statements you've made in
public that it's easier
just to assimilate whatever's going on
into the statements you've already made
and defend your you know your
long-standing beliefs because then you
you avoid the discomfort of doubt and
you get the comfort of conviction
right and i think that that part is
clear
right we we understand why that happens
i think the the undoing
the rethinking the unlearning of those
beliefs is a heck of a lot harder
and i think the the most interesting
thing that i've learned lately
is that there's there's some research on
what's called the cynical genius
illusion
uh where when somebody's cynical people
tend to assume that means they're smart
because they don't accept things that
face value it's actually the opposite
people who are extremely cynical tend to
be lower in intelligence than their
peers
and of course there's a big difference
between cynicism and skepticism right
cynicism is is not believing anything
you hear
and skepticism is being a critical
thinker and saying
show me the evidence right and one of
the reasons that
cynicism seems to emerge is it's a
defense mechanism
against being manipulated and it's a
defense mechanism that people gravitate
toward
if they get manipulated a lot because
they're not that smart
and i think the ways that we try to
attack that
are just it's like dumping fuel on a
fire
because the first thing that you know
that quote unquote the elite does or
that the mainstream media does or that
universities do is we go and accuse
people of believing stupid things
and their fear is that they're not smart
and that's why they're clinging to these
conspiracies in the first place
because they make they make them feel
smart and so i think we need to be
really careful
about you know about threatening
people's intelligence about
questioning people's you know about
questioning people's ability
to to form judgments and reason and i
think there are better ways to surface
that which we could talk about but
that that was an aha moment for me yeah
it seems like
although intelligence iq and eq
are important we also have to consider
uh you know other aspects of of of
people's lives like the extent to which
they're disenfranchised they're
alienated they're frustrated in their
path
and how those things you know uh uh
motivate
people to cotton on to ideas that
otherwise they would you know think
better of
yeah i i think that's right and you know
one of the things i've learned and you
you know this from the book
but i haven't i certainly didn't think
much about how to apply it to
to these kinds of conspiracy theories
when i was writing the book
it turns out that how questions tend to
be more powerful than why questions
you go to somebody who believes
something that that you think is
is not consistent with the truth and you
ask them why they believe what they
believe
and they have a bunch of pre-made
reasons that they find compelling
if instead you ask them well how did
that come to be
or how does that work they're much more
likely to see the gaps in their own
understanding and to recognize the
complexity of the issue
and i actually had a chance to to apply
this recently i was talking with a
friend
who believes in some vaccine
conspiracies
that you know the government and big
pharma are in cahoots to
basically pull the wool over your eyes
and convince you that vaccines
are much safer than they really are i
said look i
i i first of all some conspiracies are
real
let's let's put that on the table and we
can make a list of them
secondly i know that there are plenty of
vaccines that have documented
side effects and risks and we can look
even at the published evidence right in
peer-reviewed journals and say look this
is this is a complex issue
what i want to understand though is that
if this is so much worse than you think
it is
why is there not a single scientist with
tenure
who's willing to go against the the
establishment right in a world where the
incentive is to
be right not to just toe the party line
and also why can you not find a single
credible journalist
who wants to win a pulitzer prize for
exposing this conspiracy
and he couldn't really answer those
questions and then i i
went a step further and i said okay and
just help me think through how a giant
government bureaucracy
and all these pharma companies wouldn't
have a single internal whistleblower
and how they you think they're
incompetent right you told me they're
incompetent
how how would they have even
orchestrated this
to you know to keep the facts from
everybody
uh who's you know who's in that world
and as he thought through how to do this
he said well
you know maybe maybe maybe they couldn't
have
maybe you know people just haven't
wanted to publish the studies that you
know they cast doubt on vaccine efficacy
or safety and
maybe those are underrepresented in the
peer-reviewed journals
and that was a much more reasonable
place than he started mm-hmm
right so the idea and this was the
subject of this new york times
opinion piece basically that that came
out the other day
um the idea being that you approach
these conversations
rather than from the paradigm that you
outline in the book which is
as prosecutor as preacher or as
politician but rather
lead with curiosity ask a lot of
questions
and receive the answers to those
questions without judgment
but rather more curiosity
that's the goal is that accurate yeah i
think that's a great summary of
of both the mindset of approaching this
like a scientist
right and saying look i'm not going to
preach that i'm right i'm not going to
prosecute you for being wrong
but i'm also not going to be a
politician and just tell you what you
want to hear
to try to campaign for your approval
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to as a scientist i'm going to
say you know
rich this is totally fascinating to me
that your beliefs are so different from
mine
and i genuinely want to understand them
better and
if you could help me make sense of how
this works and how this played out
and then you know i also want to
understand i'm sure
i have some beliefs that are wrong i
suspect you also do too right nobody
nobody is omniscient
i'd love to understand what kind of
information
would lead you to consider changing your
mind and i'm also
thrilled to talk about what might change
my mind and then the hope is we're both
going to find out that our knowledge was
incomplete through this conversation and
of course it doesn't work if that's a
tactic right because the other person
will see right through it
but if you adopt what counseling
psychologists call motivational
interviewing
and you really try to understand the
person's reasons for change
and what would lead them to consider
shifting their opinion a little bit
then you might surface information that
would lead them to change their own mind
[Music]
you